we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors steadymd lets you maintain a
meaningful long-lasting relationship
with a primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started i want to talk
today about something that
will become a bigger and bigger issue
over the next couple of years when it
comes to the
things that joe biden and democrats want
to do
and the fact that there will be
resistance from the republican party
that's not
like the typical resistance we've seen
in the past
from more traditional republicans but a
more
sort of pernicious and extreme
resistance which completely poisons the
well
for people that want to have good faith
debates about what policy
should be and i think the best way to
sort of explain what i'm talking about
is to
imagine it through the lens of one issue
let's pick the issue of taxes to discuss
this just
for the sake of selecting something
there is no
one right answer on what tax rates
should be
and what tax brackets should be and what
should be
tax deductions versus tax credits versus
nothing at all
these are real topics over which there
is serious debate
there's a lot of academic literature for
example which suggests the top marginal
tax rate
for generating the most government
revenue should be 70 percent
but beyond that it can start to be a
disincentive for people to work but even
if you agree on 70
at what level of income should that rate
kick in
should it be 2 million a year or 10 or
20 million dollars a year
there are really good debates there that
that's not there's not one answer to
that question
there are real debates as to whether
lower no income tax states are really
cheaper to live in or in a state with no
income tax
are you saving on income tax but there's
higher sales tax on average and higher
property tax on average so like is a no
income
tax state really cheaper overall or is
it just
an illusion meant to attract people with
a political statement we have no state
income tax
when you pay more in other types of
taxes okay that's a great
thing to explore we can debate whether
people should pay any taxes at all if
they earn under ten thousand dollars a
year
or twenty thousand dollars a year or
thirty thousand dollars a year or
should they get a tax credit versus a
low tax rate or
where should phase-outs begin for
certain programs welfare programs or tax
credits or whatever
what about universal basic income there
are good debates
being had there and all of these are
debates that can be had in good faith
with people who disagree about the
answer like i have an opinion about all
of those issues and i recognize there
are people with other opinions
who are uh discussing these issues in
good faith they're operating within the
realm of what's reasonable they have
valid points to make and these are the
people we need to engage with
the problem here is when extremists
poison the well
by introducing ideas that aside from
making no
sense are never going to be a reality so
like when you
interject the people who say all taxes
are theft or all taxes are slavery
as a starting point or all taxes should
be abolished as a starting point
this is the united states this is a
country of 331 million people
we're not getting rid of all taxes the
idea of taxes as slavery
is not going to push the debate forward
as to what tax policy should be
or people who say you know we should put
a 99 percent tax on
incomes over a million dollars no one
should be allowed to make over a million
it's not going to happen guys we're
getting nowhere with that as the
starting point and i'm going to
distinguish in a moment
extremist poisoning the well versus
productive
uh stretching of the overton window
these are two different things
so the people who say you know these
things
they are often asserting that we should
include these ideas because we don't
want to suppress
speech and we don't want to censor ideas
i agree with that but as i've said
before not every hair-brained idea
deserves a seat at the adult table when
we're discussing policy
so we often talk about moving the
overton window for example
the more we talk about medicare for all
is the gold standard
the more a public option seems to be a
centrist idea
which it is the more we talk about two
thousand dollars
per month in coronavirus stimulus the
more
that a single two thousand dollar
payment seems like a pretty centrist
idea
which it is and so we want to use the
overton window to better our negotiating
ability but
taxes are slavery doesn't improve
anyone's negotiating ability it's just a
crazy idea
and this is how these new extremists in
the house of representatives are going
to be poisoning the well
not necessarily on taxes but this is the
the idea of it
and making it impossible for democrats
to do anything which they've admitted
they plan to do
so as a result as we spoke about
yesterday
i'm completely on board with what we
learned bernie sanders plans to do and
that's use budget reconciliation to get
as much done as possible in the senate
with a simple majority rather than
requiring 60 votes meaning they don't
need a single republican assuming
that all 50 democrats are on the same
page
there unfortunately is no other way with
people who are fundamentally bad faith
actors now i'm willing to have my mind
changed
but what good will the idea of
bipartisanship
do when it just means allowing
completely ridiculous ideas to be part
of the conversation
and completely absurd people to slow
down the possibility of progress
so there's the debate about the
filibuster that continues
there's the idea of unity and
bipartisanship that joe biden has
expressed as a goal
as i've said before i don't think it's
going to happen and this is exactly why
these extremist ideas poison the well
and we're seeing it happen already on
fox
news we're seeing it on oan we're seeing
it on newsmax and
i believe that while i am willing to
have my mind changed the idea of
bipartisanship
merely if that means allowing ridiculous
radical reactionary ideas into the
debate does nothing good for anybody
and democrats should simply prep plow
through it for these next
at least two years during which they
will have control of the house senate
and the white house
if you disagree with me let me know i
received a ton of emails
about this one of the most common
requests
for segments i've gotten over the last
couple of weeks
is from people who write in and say some
version of i have a trumpist conspiracy
theorist
family member or friend or co-worker
i don't know how to talk to them i don't
want to
make anybody angry but in some way
i feel the need to try to knock some
sense into them proverbially not
physically
and i don't even know where to start and
in the past
depending on the relationship with the
person i say well
you have to decide your approach will
depend on
how aggressive you're willing to get are
you willing to ruin this relationship
if these are presumably people you have
to continue to be around cordially
because they're co-workers
or family members or friends that you
love and want to continue being around
i believe the best approach is a sort of
gentle probing
socratic method of questioning asking
people to think about
how they came to the conclusions they
came to and hopefully some fraction of
them
will say oh the basis on which i've come
to hold these beliefs isn't that strong
let me let me sort of re-examine it
that's the
the best i've suggested we can really
hope for if you want to go with the
gentle probing idea charlie watson
wrote a really great opinion piece in
the new york times
called how to talk to friends and family
who share conspiracy theories
which contains a lot of really important
information and i thought we would go
over some of the basics and
i i recognize that when when i've talked
about a socratic method of questioning
one of the questions that comes up
regularly is
what exactly are the types of questions
that i should be asking so let's start
there
first of all almost exclusively
the best place to start when someone
shares a conspiracy theory on facebook
or in person at thanksgiving or whatever
the case may be
is where is the information coming from
where did you where did you
learn that how did you come to believe
that thing that you just told me
this is useful because it opens the door
to later asking and how do you know that
you can trust that source
how do you know the information is
trustworthy so it's useful for that
reason
it's also useful because it helps you
understand the sort of information
environment where
are some people getting this stuff some
might be getting it from facebook
others may be hearing it at work so
that's very important
the next step as i sort of alluded to
would be asking people how they've
determined
that the information is trustworthy how
have they determined that their source
of information
can be believed what about it makes it
believable
how would they know if it were not
believable these are
generally relatively inoffensive
questions that you can ask with a
genuine curiosity to establish their
system of belief
and they can get people to start they
can get the the gears moving
how do you identify something that would
be less believable
and a lot of this is not necessarily
for you to understand their level of
media literacy although that is useful
but again
inject the idea that they need a process
for thinking about have i properly
vetted and evaluated the conspiracy or
the fake news that i'm sharing right now
and then maybe the hardest part is to
really follow through
on the assumption that if their
conspiracy theory was real
then what other things would have to be
real and this one requires a little more
knowledge and nuance
imagine that you're right about this
conspiracy theory
imagine that what you're saying is true
what would happen next
what are you anticipating it would mean
in terms of this or of that and
there's a really good example i'll try
to re this is on my twitter i'll try to
reshare it if i can find it
i retweeted a really good twitter thread
that i went over last week on a stream
where there was like a hollywood
screenwriter talking to a conspiracy
theorist woman back and forth on twitter
and he actually did this he engaged with
her ideas which started with
there's a plan for trump to remain
president that she was posting this on
january 21st obviously trump was gone
but
she was saying there is a plan for trump
to remain president after the
inauguration
and this guy started asking specific
questions okay
how will it be carried out through what
mechanism
will trump be back in office and biden
be gone
well he's going to be arrested okay what
will he be arrested
for and eventually the woman came to the
claim
that joe biden had actually already died
and been replaced with an imposter at
some point in the past
and it was fascinating to see the
questions that followed which included
oh
how did biden die was it of natural
causes disease or did somebody kill him
if he was killed who killed him how was
it covered up how many people would have
needed to be involved in that to replace
biden with an imposter with nobody
knowing
why did they even need to kill him like
in other words if biden was going to
steal the election either way why do you
need a fake biden to steal the election
from donald trump why not
just have the real biden steal the
election from donald trump
uh and although this particular woman
was clearly
too far beyond reach what was
interesting
was that it was a really good example of
the types of questions that for some
people can actually get them to say
maybe there's something about this that
doesn't make sense really important
last thought on this just because a
belief isn't based on a solid foundation
doesn't mean people will give it up
easily and remember
that just because this idea this system
doesn't work on one person doesn't mean
that it's the wrong
method we looked at that focus group
with 12 trumpists last week
only one of the 12 was willing to
re-examine his beliefs and see reason
so this a lot of people aren't even
open to this but for those that are
i find that this method seems to be the
best one
let me know your thoughts if you've had
success with this method let me know
if you failed with this method also let
me know i'm on twitter at the pacman the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
co-pays
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me and my medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
[Music]
video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the only place to get genuine david
pakman show memberships is join
pacman.com accept no substitutes if
someone calls you and says they're
offering memberships we don't
sell memberships by phone if you get a
letter saying
send us a check for a membership we
don't solicit memberships by a mail
the one place to get a membership is
joinedpakman.com and i hope that you
will
over the last five or i guess now we're
on day
really oh wow today's actually the the
beginning of day
seven of the biden presidency we have
seen a dramatic change in what press
briefings
look like kaylee mcinanny who was
trump's press secretary was replaced
with jen sackey who is joe biden's press
secretary
and for the most part she answers the
questions that are asked she's still a
press secretary when it's not
advantageous to answer she won't but
we're actually getting valuable
information about what's going on with
joe biden now
one of the additional characters that
has sort of come to prominence
uh during the gen saki era is
the son of fox and friends anchor steve
ducey
named peter ducey peter ducey is steve
ducey's son
and he i guess is now part of the white
house press corps
and he has made it a habit to ask the
most
aggressive question he can and good for
him
except that it's not good journalism
they're just sort of really dumb gotcha
type questions
and hilariously jenn sackey actually
called peter ducey steve ducey a couple
of times
so this is like a whole little
subculture thing that's developing in
the white house
press briefings and i want to look at
some clips with you it really does seem
as though peter ducey is trying to make
himself known
as the tough guy who's willing to hold
gen saki accountable
except it just implodes hilariously
every time
here is one uh clip from when dr fauci
joined jen saki last week at her first
or second press briefing
and uh peter ducey uh asked dr fauci
about rumors that amazon was now
offering to get involved with covid19
and right-wingers say it's bias amazon
refused to help trump
now they want to help joe biden in order
to make him look good
here is dr fauci asked about that by
peter ducey
yeah how helpful would it have been if
amazon
got involved with the federal response
to
kobe 19 before biden
took office and do you know about any
plans or discussions
ahead of yesterday no i don't think i
could answer that
question i'd be waving my hands about
that sorry
well you know one of the new things in
this administration is if you don't know
the answer
don't guess just say you don't know the
answer yeah
yes now of course this has nothing to do
with dr
fauci peter ducey is i get it peter
ducey is implying
amazon has political motivations for not
helping
trump and offering to help biden that's
if it's
true that amazon didn't offer to help
trump i don't know we don't know the
answer to that
but the questions about amazon's
involvement during a prior
administration either need to go from to
someone from that administration
who was working on supply and logistics
which dr fauci was not
or to amazon the idea that that's a
question for dr fauci is hilarious and
peter ducey tried the same thing with
jen sackey the white house press
secretary
the did the transition officials know
before yesterday that amazon wanted to
get involved
in such a meaningful way
not that i'm aware of i'm happy to check
i mean when the reporting came out
i asked the question and i think uh
internally and you know what
was conveyed to me and i don't think we
discussed this yesterday was that
we've had a lot of outreach um some
privately some publicly from a range of
businesses and private sector entities
and we certainly welcome that
and uh we'll be considering all of those
offers and what makes the most sense in
our
uh plans and proposals so because there
are some trump officials saying they
were never offered help from amazon and
so they're
essentially saying they think this was a
political call for amazon to wait
while lives were hanging the balance but
you're saying that
it's not the case i'm not aware of the
timeline of when amazon reached out that
sounds like a question for amazon to me
and that's exactly right did they reach
out to the trump administration i don't
know ask the trump administration
or ask amazon it's not really a question
for joe biden
why are they interested now what that's
a question for amazon it's not a
question for dr fauci
or for gen saki then he goes to
isn't it divisive that there will be
impeachment
i'm sorry i told you i was gonna ask you
i just skipped over here go ahead
i'll take it now uh so if president
biden wants
a theme of his presidency to be unifying
the country does he think
that nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
should drop a potentially
divisive senate impeachment trial the
answer
should be the same every single time
joe biden will play no role whatsoever
in the impeachment trial
he is not going to try to get anyone in
the senate to do anything
he is not going to try to influence
anyone in the senate not to do anything
joe biden was not in the senate when the
house voted
on impeachment joe biden is not in the
senate now
it would be inappropriate for joe biden
to exert any influence one way or the
other
he will remain totally out of it that is
the exact right answer and that's the
answer that should be given
every single time peter ducey then also
asked why didn't joe biden wear a mask
on quote federal lands during the
inauguration
at the lincoln memorial go ahead why
weren't
president biden and all members of the
biden family matt
at all times on federal lands last night
if he signed
an executive order that mandates masks
on federal
lands at all times at the inaugural
memorial yes and of course they
basically
were wearing masks most of the time
masks did come off at one point for some
photographs
it was just biden's family together
probably a bad
look but the idea that this is a gotcha
question
when the trump administration's mis
handling of the virus
led to probably more than 100 000
unnecessary deaths
it's just ridiculous here is peter ducey
trying to call out joe biden
for putting in place travel restrictions
now
after previously calling donald trump's
travel restrictions xenophobic
and just one more about the announcement
you made off the top about the travel
restrictions
when president trump was imposing travel
restrictions in march specifically
on china then candidate biden
called it xenophobic and fear-mongering
so
now president biden is putting travel
restrictions on people coming in from
other countries
what words we use to describe that now
this is just not true
this has been repeated ad nauseam biden
said it was xenophobic he said the
travel restrictions were xenophobic
the truth is that biden supported covet
travel restrictions
and he called trump xenophobic
but not for the covid travel
restrictions this is one of those where
you
if you repeat it enough times it sort of
becomes true but
joe biden didn't say the covid
restrictions were xenophobic he
supported them
and he also said that donald trump was
xenophobic
for other reasons yesterday joe biden
interestingly deliberately picking peter
ducey
knowing that ducey asks him sandbagging
questions check this out
uh ducey sort of asks a weird question
about shutting down the virus and joe
biden handles it perfectly well
now wait wait wait i know he always asks
me tough questions
and he always has an edge to them but i
like him anyway so go ahead and ask
the answer to ask the question thank you
mr president uh
so you just said that you think within
three weeks or so
we'll be at the point where there are a
million vaccines
per day but it seems like i think we'll
get there before that
i said i hope i misspoke i hope we'll be
able to increase
as we go around till we get to the
million five a day that's my ex
my hope and then my the follow-up to
that would be i
now that you're president and you're
saying there's nothing we can do to
change the trajectory of the pandemic in
the next
several months what happened to two
months ago when you
were talking declaratively about i am
going to shut down
the virus well i'm going to shut down
the virus but not i never said i'd do it
in two months i said it took a long time
to get here
it's going to take a long time to beat
it and so we have millions of people out
there who are
who have the virus we're just for the
first day i think correct me if i'm
wrong i've been doing other things
this morning speaking with foreign
leaders but one of the things i think
this is one of the first days that the
numbers actually come down the number of
deaths
and the number on a daily basis and the
number of hospitalizations etc
it's going to take time it's going to
take a heck of a lot of time
and we still have as dr fauci constantly
points out
it's one thing when we have mass
how can i say it politely mass disregard
of the warnings about
not wearing masks and wearing masks and
and social distancing
and failure to social distance and
people getting together on
holidays in ways that weren't
recommended etc we
see first thing that happens is we see
the uh
the number of infections go up then you
see the hospitalizations go up then you
see the deaths go up
so remember that as reported yesterday
69 percent of the country
approves of joe biden's week one
handling of the pandemic
but regardless joe biden not phased
not thrown off by uh peter ducey there
and i think this is how ducey is going
to try to become more well-known during
this presidency i think that the
uh oan reporter i think it's oan chanel
ryan
also tried to become known for asking
certain types of questions during the
trump administration the problem was
she was very very bad oh where's that
noise coming i
apologize for that she was very very bad
at asking the questions
and so she never really became uh super
well known
ducey seems better at least at
formulating the questions and he may
very
well end up uh be becoming relatively
known for
dropping tough questions on gensake and
joe biden but so far
the questions are all quite dumb this is
very
interesting we have the first approval
rating for president joe biden
it's 63 percent this is the highest
approval rating
at any time for any president
dating back 12 years to 2009
to find an approval rating for a
president higher than
joe biden's current approval rating of
63 percent
you have to go all the way back to 2009
barack obama's first year in the white
house
when obama hit 69 percent approval
note that donald trump never got to even
50 approval even one time during his
entire presidency now there's a couple
different things going on here
there is such a dramatic shift in covid
policy which is one of the top
issues for most americans right now from
trump who couldn't have failed more
miserably to biden who's at least trying
and we'll see what degree of success he
has
i think covet explains a lot of the
shift to a high approval rating for joe
biden
in addition presidents often have their
best approval ratings at the very
beginning
before they've done things that their
political opponents can say are bad
or done things that are actually bad
george w bush was different in that way
george w bush's approval rating
skyrocketing
i think to eight was it 88 um
after 9 11 which was not um which which
was a bit of a ways in
months in uh to george w bush's
presidency but typically this is when
january february march of their first
term this is when presidents have their
highest approval so
it's not totally shocking that biden's
doing okay now the fact that he's at 63
is quite interesting we've not seen an
approval that high for a president in 12
years now being realistic biden probably
settles below 63 percent if he can
really turn the pandemic around in the
next four to six months
maybe he could get to 68 maybe he could
get to 70. remember that right now
about 30 percent of this country is
completely whackadoo
okay and uh it's very hard for me to
imagine that biden's ceiling
is much higher than 70 or 72 percent
anyway so maybe a successful biden
can peak at 67 68 maybe 70 and a
successful biden
would probably settle somewhere around
the mid-50s
if he does well if he does as poorly as
trump then you'd expect to see him in
the high 30s low 40s
uh the way that donald trump does the
the real test for biden
will be these next three to six months
what happens with the virus what happens
with vaccination we
we are up now up to a one and a quarter
million vaccinations a day which is
great
and what happens when unemployment
expires for a lot of people
there are some major tests coming for
joe biden but these early numbers
very very interesting to see and at
least to the degree that a
hyper-polarized country
can be united behind what a president is
doing
63 approval and 69 percent approval of
covid so far
in this first week it is significant to
pretend it's not
would be dismissive of something that is
significant
this is when you expect to see
presidents with some of their higher
approvals
let's check in again about this in four
to six weeks let's take a quick break
make sure you're following the show
on instagram at david pakman show
and while you're there follow me on
instagram
david.pacman the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today david shore who's a data scientist
who consults with democratic groups and
has
a number of insights into many different
areas
of uh the political world is is the way
i say it uh glad glad to have you here
today
uh pleasure to be here so let's just
start with 2020 polling
i mean there the the how how off or on
was it certainly joe biden was winning
the popular vote polling
and he won the popular vote and he
became the president there were
certainly some states
in which the numbers leading up to the
election
did not quite work out i mean what's
your sort of overall assessment of
what's happening with polling right now
yeah well first i as as a i guess
disclaimer i think in some ways it's
funny that going into election night
we thought that joe biden would win and
the democrats would get 50 or 51 senate
seats and you know the end result joe
biden is president democrats do a 50
senate seats
uh so i think that is kind of funny but
you know that said
the polling was actually fairly bad
this year you know just to put numbers
on it uh i think
there's kind of two distinct problems
you know with polling you know one
is just that uh we really
the numbers were way too high for
democrats uh on average there was about
a three percent
uh bias toward democrats and that's in
vote share which means that in terms of
margin you're looking at you know
roughly six percent
this happened on basically every level
of government on the senate on the house
you know in the presidency and you know
if you were looking at polls
you would expect you were coming in
expecting that biden was going to win
states like florida
that we would have you know maybe like a
bunch of democratic seats and that we
were supposed to pick up 10 seats in the
house and
you know none of those things happened
and then i think on top of that
you know it's not just that the polling
on average you know was uh was too
democratic
but the kind of uh error pattern by
state
you know really matched what we saw in
2016 and you know what we saw in 2018
where these kind these states in the
midwest with a lot of you know
non-college educated whites
uh really uh we saw a strong
overestimation of support i think there
was a
you know a canopy act poll or in
wisconsin right before the election
where it said that biden would win by 15
and he ended up you know winning by less
than one
uh so yeah i think it was a pretty bad
cycle for polling and then just the last
angle just through account you know all
the ways the polls were bad this year
is just in terms of looking at
coalitions you know the big changes
in this election roughly speaking were
that non-college whites were you know
basically where they were in 2016.
college-educated whites swung something
like six or seven percent toward us
you know african-americans swung two
points uh down and i think hispanic
voters you know now that all the data's
in looks like they dropped by like nine
percent
and the polls didn't really see any of
those trends coming there was like a
little bit
of warning signs you know with non-white
voters though it ended up being worse
than the polls thought
but if you looked at the polls the polls
really told this story that we were
going to see
education depolarization that
non-college whites were going to
trend toward democrats and
college-educated whites were going to
you know stay
basically where they were last time and
that just didn't happen you know if you
look at
uh if you just look at the college
non-college gap it looks like the polls
were off by something like 10 or 11
percent which is
crazy um in a lot of ways the polls were
a lot worse than 2016.
so let's dig into one aspect of this
which is that the concept of polling is
you can't pull everybody so the idea is
you get a representative sample and what
does it mean that it's representative
often we're talking about well
we'll normalize it for education or we
can normalize it for race we can
normalize it for political affiliation
you can normalize it for age all of
these different things
but one of the things you really can't
normalize for correct me if i'm wrong
is the types of people that are more
likely to participate in a poll
versus the types of people that are more
likely to opt out and we heard this
from some on the right who who kind of
said it as
a lot of trumpists don't trust the polls
so they either give deliberately fake
answers or don't participate
and there's no great way to deal with
that as a pollster
how much truth is there to the general
idea of
people willing to and not willing to
participate and then maybe more
specifically to some of the explanations
that were given by
supporters of the president of former
president trump
yeah i i think in some ways i think
there's something to the story i do want
to be clear
that if you ask someone who they're
going to vote for in a survey they do
generally tell you the truth
because it's not an issue with trolling
but you know that said
i think one of the big drivers for why
the polling was so wrong this year and
why it was actually worse than 2016
uh was that there were really giant you
know differences in who was answering uh
the phone you know something that
you know the way that uh you know the
firm i worked for the way that they do
polling
they actually match people back to uh
voter files and so we can see their
party registration and something that
was really clear
is that starting around march democrats
became much more likely
you know to answer the phone than
republicans and i think it's it's kind
they kind of stayed at these elevated
levels throughout the entire election
and i think there's a pretty clear story
that this had a lot to do with lockdown
that democrats were literally home
there's like a lot of cell phone
mobility data that really shows that
democrats stayed home and they didn't
really have much to do and they started
answering surveys at high rates
and republicans weren't doing that and
you know they just weren't uh picking up
the phones
but you know generalizing you know that
was an issue with this year and i i
think it was uh clear
um but even in 2016 you know when we
look back
at why the polls were wrong and i think
this bias continued now
like why is it that pollsters have such
a hard time
measuring opinion in states that have a
lot of working-class white people
and originally people really talked
about this
in terms of trump turning out a lot of
new voters and i think that there's a
lot of evidence now that that's not
really true
that you know all of these election
switches were really driven by people
changing their minds as opposed to
changes and who voted
but then the question is why did why
were the polls wrong and
why were the polls wrong in more
in working class areas and it kind of
comes back to this concept of social
trust
that political scientists and uh
sociologists like to talk about
and so that's just operationalized with
this question of do you think that
people can be trusted or do you think
that people should
keep to themselves and something that's
pretty wild just socially
is that you know the government's been
asking this on a very high quality
survey they spend a couple thousand
dollars per person and they get like a
70
response rate phone response rates are
closer to one percent you know just for
reference point
and they've been asking it since the
670s and
it used to be that you know roughly 55
percent of people said that
people could be trusted and that figure
is down to 30 percent
so that's sociologically that's
sociologically very concerning um though
above my pay grade
but it has measurement implications uh
because people who trust
um people who say that people can be
trusted
kind of unsurprisingly are a lot more
likely to answer phone surveys
and that used to not matter very much
because how much you trusted the people
around you and how much you trust
institutions just used to not be that
correlated with partisanship
uh but in 2016 you know donald trump
really reshaped the coalition
uh you know if 2012 was a coal it was a
basically
uh you know a fight over whether or not
we should have universal health care
2016 was much more of a referendum on
like how much do you trust the people
around you
and we were only talking in these
surveys to these high trust people who
say that people can be trusted
and if you and you know there was
literally this hidden
you know hidden majority of low trust
folks who
went in the other direction and so you
know we've actually looked in crosstalk
and if you look
among people who said that people could
be trusted that group swung toward
democrats by
you know something like four or five
percent but the other group went
completely in the opposite direction
and you know this high trust sample that
was the people we were polling and
that's the world we expected to see on
election day
um but then they didn't actually answer
and you know the same thing
you know actually you know people don't
realize happened in 2018 democrats won
so they didn't notice but if you look at
the actual margins in places like
west virginia places like michigan
places like ohio
the elections were much closer than
people than you know the polls
originally thought
even if uh even if we ended up winning
and then we see the same thing again you
know in uh in 2020 uh
and i and i think that uh social trust
is a very important you know angle for
understanding it
one of the things i saw you to shift
gears a little bit i i read some of your
tweets about which i find very
interesting is about the bias of the
electoral college
and you posted a couple things that i
find really interesting one is that you
you posted the partisan bias of the
electoral college over time and one of
the things you found is that
democrats now need about 52 percent of
the vote in order to have a 50-50
shot of winning the presidency given
that it's not the national popular vote
that decides but but rather the
electoral vote
and then the other really interesting
thing is that
there's this notion that part of what
makes the electoral college
depart in terms of its orientation from
the popular vote
is that small states are really
overweighted relative to their
populations and you pointed out
something very interesting which is that
in terms of the difference makers when
it comes down to who ultimately wins the
electoral college
it's more about the fact that there are
some larger population states
which are relatively close could be 52
48 could be 55 45 60 40.
but because they are winner take all you
are essentially
i don't know if the right word is
disenfranchising but if you're part of
the 42 percent of democrats in a big red
state
your vote essentially doesn't matter for
calculating the electoral college can
you talk a little bit
about that yeah absolutely
uh i i think it's just important to
you know say that the bias in the
electoral college i think
is very new you know it is true that you
know gore won the popular vote and
lost the electoral college but the bias
of the electoral college was really
quite small that year
you know gore got something like 50.2
percent
and and you know uh he very very very
narrowly lost um and so that
you know that was like random and not
really that big a deal and really the
electoral college at various points is
favored democrats you know it's if
uh if barack obama in 2012 had gotten
about 49.5 percent of the vote
he actually still you know probably
would have won that's that's why people
talk about the blue wall there
there are basically these big this is
just a little bit of a history lesson
but you know they're
they're just these big midwestern states
that
kind of had their economies centered
around farming and manufacturing and as
a result
you know they have rel they're both you
know relatively white and also have
relatively low education levels relative
to the rest of the country
and the electoral college really comes
down to who does
well in these places and in 2012 you
know obama a lot of his appeal was he
actually did very well
you know with midwestern whites he did
better in the midwest than carrie and
really than a lot of democrats before
him
uh and but he also did well enough among
college educated whites to make places
like virginia and colorado competitive
so the electoral college had like a
small bias in his favor
2016 totally changed that though and
you know it's really great if you can
see the graph because you know just kind
of wiggles around zero and then there's
just this sudden plunge
um to there being i think a three point
uh
you know a three-point gap uh by us in
in the republican favor
and i think that that's you know the
really under appreciated part of
understanding 2016
which is that barack obama got about 52
percent of the two-party vote
uh in 2012 and hillary clinton got
51.1 of the vote and in any other
democracy
that would have been fine you know a 0.9
percent decline
still you know comfortably above 50. um
but the problem was that the
electoral college shifted from being
about half a point bias in favor of
democrats
to being three points bias in favor of
republicans and then that bias
increased again uh and so
it's helpful to put numbers on these
things and you know just to get to your
other question i think people really
don't understand why the electoral
college causes this bias you know as you
said it's not that you have these
tiny states it's not about wyoming
in order to get to 270 states you have
to win states like
wisconsin like minnesota like ohio and
there just happened to be a bunch of
relatively evenly divided states that
right now are somewhat more
republican than the country overall and
i think the
you know the key point is that the
reason why this happened
is because democrats have started doing
so much worse
among working-class white people and you
know unless that gets reversed
i think it's unlikely that this is gonna
that this is gonna revert you know i
think a lot of people expected
that you know things would get better
this year and the key point is that
the bias went from three points in 2016
to four points in 2020
and so it really just shows how
unworkable you know our coalition is
under this set of rules
uh absolutely fundamental insights to
understand really in thinking about
future elections i mean if you if if one
does not understand
reality as it is it's hard to run a
campaign that that is based on that
reality
uh we've been speaking with david shore
who's a data scientist who consults with
democratic groups
you uh certainly should follow him on
twitter as i do david i
i so appreciate your time today oh thank
you so much
a pleasure to be here the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon
patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's take a whirlwind tour
through
religious media over the last six days
with you
it's very interesting what's happening
in religious right media
right now absent evidence that is
convincing in a court which was all
thrown out over the last two months
religious media has been taking a
prophecy approach
to donald trump being the real winner
of the november 2020 presidential
election they've been taking the
approach that
god or the bible or prophecy or
uh sacred text can explain what is
happening with joe biden
and it can be the source of hope that
donald trump is going to somehow
reappear in the oval office sometime
very soon and this is really amazing now
as you know i believe this is delusion i
believe that this is a form of mental
illness
if it's not merely a grift to make money
okay it may just be a scam but i believe
if the things you're going to hear
now are real beliefs i believe that it's
that is mental illness
and um i i want to be sort of really
clear
when people say uh you know it's it's
rude to call this mental illness
i'm going to explain more about this i
don't think there's anything rude
whatsoever about what i'm saying
let's take a look at the first clip this
is right-wing pastor hank
kahneman who prophesied or prophesized
prophesied
i don't know he predicted that a trump's
re-election
would happen he's now fighting back
against people who were saying
you were wrong hank you said that trump
was going to be reelected
maybe you were a false prophet and
kahneman says well god hates it when you
say that
he didn't say he hates discord
he hates he
he he hates you
that are being a troll he hates
you that are attacking your christian
brothers
and sisters
yeah but they're false they're wrong
excuse me
how do you know because it doesn't come
to pass how do you know that it hasn't
come to pass
first of all the president was
re-elected
let's get that clear second of all he
was given
a second term based on re-election
well he's not serving it now because it
was stolen
by thieves
doesn't that make sense to everyone just
perfectly clear now again
if he believes that i believe that that
is deep mental illness and i know some
of you are going to write to me you'll
say david
that's alienating to the religious folks
in your audience it's offensive to all
religious people and i'm here to tell
you the answer is no
if you are nominally catholic for
example and you go to church
and you believe there's some greater
power at play
but you're not so deluded that you think
god is controlling elections or that joe
biden has the mark of the beast or
god is speaking through people like hank
kahneman you and i might disagree
i'd say you know i don't see evidence
for your understanding of the world
but i wouldn't say that you're deluded
or mentally ill nominally jewish beliefs
about a greater
force could be a god could be something
else some kind of energy that's not this
this
is something else let's not conflate
when i say
this is deep delusion this
with the nominally religious beliefs
that tens of millions of americans hold
there is a difference here even if i
don't subscribe to either of them there
is a difference here
here is right-wing pastor greg locke
declaring that joe biden is an imposter
a false prophet an illegitimate
president whose presidency
is not only false it's also demonic my
favorite moment is when people start to
hold their hands up in the air as greg
lock
talks there ain't one place in the whole
bible
that god ever even remotely encourages
me
to accept something that we know is
demonic and false
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
joe biden is not
the president of the united states of
america as far as greg
locke is concerned he's a liar he's an
imposter he's a false prophet
he's an illegitimate president that did
not win and i don't care
if you send him my name my phone number
and my mug shot that comes across his
desk i ain't scared of his executive
orders
i bow before jesus christ the king of
kings and the lord of lord i don't care
what the news says
i don't care what the fbi says i don't
care what fox
and cnn or newsmax said i'm telling you
god is about to turn this whole thing
around if you believe that give him a
shot of praise this morning
give him a shout of praise and maybe
drop a 20
bill in the hat please right that is
either a straight
up grift or a mentally ill person period
after the inauguration religious right
activist
elizabeth enlo insists trump will return
to
office and she declares that she will
not recognize
someone who was illegally elected as
president notice
and this if you're watching i guess it's
her husband sitting next to her
he just smiles as she says this stuff as
if she's making a lot of sense and as if
he's really proud
i do believe that president trump
will be back in that position of
authority
even though there was an inauguration
yesterday
i do not and will not recognize
someone who has illegally been
elected as my president i just can't do
that and
you know i'll cut to the chase people
will ask some have already asked us
well at what point would you um
kind of transition into letting go of
contending for
you know president trump being our next
president for four years
not in 2024 but like coming now
and i for me i don't know the answer to
that question i just know
when when i'll know it and it's not now
i'm not
even close to being ready to
relinquish um my faith and what god has
assured my heart of and what i'm hearing
reflected in the prophetic voices that
that i've been listening to it's funny
are these people religious
experts or election experts it's hard to
tell from the things that they're saying
and notice that the truth is in there
she says
i'm not ready to admit trump lost
everything else couching it as for as
faith as prophecy the truth about
trump's return
it's window dressing to what she
actually admits which is
i'm just not ready to accept that donald
trump simply lost which is what happened
here's one last one this is from okay so
before the election a guy named steve
schultz
of elijahlist.com said if trump doesn't
uh serve a second term i will apologize
that was his promise before
the election before the inauguration
trump is out
um biden is in but steve schultz still
won't apologize
he says god still has time to kick out
joe biden and bring donald trump back
as for mike's share all legal remedies
have come and gone they're done they're
over so then you say well then how can
you possibly believe that god could do
this
god never works with possibilities he
works with impossibility i should say
never does when he wants to
show up and show off he
he makes sure every single possibility
is exhausted
so that man can never say see i knew if
we held on long enough the supreme court
would do this or something like that so
so we're giving you these prophetic
proclamations and decrees
and just the prophetic word of the lord
not based on what we see
could happen but based on who we serve
that tells us what he's going to do
so there it is uh depending on who they
serve if they serve god or not
who knows then god might somehow
still be able to make his prophecy
correct
i just don't understand how it's going
to happen at this point but he's
refusing to apologize and definitely
keep sending money that's the
the one thing that binds all of these
folks together
is the gravy train must not stop you've
got to keep sending the money in
incredible and people get scammed by
this
people send money to these
grifters or delusional people or some
combination of the two really horrible
stuff
twitter has permanently banned my pillow
ceo mike lindell's account
after he continued to repeat bogus
claims about donald trump winning
the 2020 u.s presidential election mike
lindell has been
really a fixture of disinformation he
first appeared
more prominently early in the
coronavirus pandemic he was up alongside
trump at one of the white house press
briefings uh
talking about how trump is a gift from
god and trump talking about how mike
lindell instead of making some of his
pillows is gonna make
some ppe i never heard again about
whether mike lindell actually delivered
the ppe but that's at least what they
claimed back in
what was it maybe may or something like
that in any case
he became mike lindell became a major
player
in claiming that trump was about to win
that trump
actually won that they're going to get
biden out and trump in for a second term
and now twitter has decided to ban mike
lindell
over quote repeated violations of its
civic integrity policy
according to a twitter spokesperson
now because mike lindell has been
posting
so much of this stuff it's not actually
obvious
right now which of his exact posts
triggered this suspension in even better
news
lindell is up against the possible
lawsuit from dominion voting systems
we told you yesterday dominion voting
systems is suing rudy giuliani for 1.3
billion dollars
for his defamat they claim defamatory
claims about them
now mike lindell also may be getting
sued for his claims that dominion voting
systems
were part of some big election fraud
that he claims
exists but for which there is no
evidence he also urged trump you might
remember to declare
martial law in minnesota to obtain its
ballots and somehow overturn the
election here was mike lindell quick
reminder
at a pro-trump rally this was january
5th not january 6 the day of the
insurrection it was january 5th
talking about how trump will be
president from november 4th
on every day i have spent looking into
the election pride i've worked with
sidney powell general flynn
all the guys with these machines these
experts and i can tell you
100 percent donald trump is going to be
your president for four more years
[Applause]
i have i have never ever ever said
anything less than 100
and just today there was so much this
morning i was on the phone with general
flynn
and just even more evidence came out
these are going to be bonus evidence
just to put more people in prison
now of course no one is in prison uh joe
biden has been sworn in
and now mike lindell is under threat of
lawsuit
by dominion voting systems and suspended
from twitter
so you know i got into a little bit of
an argument with people on twitter
i believe that the my pillow guy is
dangerous
but he's dangerous not because of who or
what he is
he's made dangerous by an american
society and culture
in which lots of people fall for the
stuff he says so what i mean by that is
this
in a more normal world no one would pay
more attention to mike lindell than they
pay attention to the rantings
of that guy on the subway platform
who's screaming stuff about repenting or
whatever the case may be
in a more normal world this guy
wouldn't be alongside a president on
tv and having the platform that he has
because of american society and culture
and lack of education and media literacy
mike lindell ends up getting propped up
by trump himself by q anon types and
even by some of right-wing media
so the the the danger of mike lindell
not doesn't come just from oh it's
someone in a country of 331 million
saying crazy things
we have plenty of those people the
problem comes from the way in which our
society
is susceptible to falling four con men
like mike lindell
like trump on another level and that's
where the danger comes from so when
people say
this is just one dude how can you say
he's dangerous well he's dangerous as a
result of combining him it's sort of
like
you can have components to a poison that
by themselves aren't poisonous
when they come together it becomes a
poisonous brew
that's what we're talking about with
mike lindell mike lindell plus a
susceptible population
plus those who are susceptible that have
the ability to give this guy a
significant platform that's where the
danger comes from
hey here's an interesting voicemail you
can call me at 2192 david p
here's a guy saying how can i be calling
for unity now
when i was against the things donald
trump did when he was elected this guy
misunderstands my position but let's
take a listen
hi i got a question i'm listening to
your show today it's uh monday the 25th
and you're talking something about unity
and it's like
i don't understand um we were saying
unity four years ago
when trump was president i mean
uh i don't understand that you're saying
you want unity now but
back then you everything he did you were
against
no no no no i am not the ones demanding
unity
i'm the one saying anyone thinking there
will be unity
doesn't understand what's going on and
so this is a very very important
thing i had i was not hypocritically
demanding unity
in 2016 and uh
uh or or ignoring it then
and then now calling for it back in 2016
i was clear listen
trump won and i'm going to oppose the
things he does if i think they should be
opposed
joe biden now won and we know that we
aren't going to see any unity from the
right
joe biden is asking for unity some
republicans are asking for unity even
though for them the definition of unity
is biden
not doing anything different than donald
trump i'm not the one
calling for unity i'm the one pointing
out it's not going to happen so that
that's
certainly a misunderstanding we've got a
great bonus show today
we will talk about control of the senate
we will talk about harriet tubman on the
20
bill that is back in the news we will
talk about trump's second impeachment
trial
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
steady md lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started